yeah welcome to this video playing
vampire from Greece play my trusty
trusted trusty now a trusted in can be
five line we got a line of the Scotch
four nights yeah okay let's let's go 36
this is some slightly unusual way to
play d 5 more castles and defy the stuff
far more how a more known apart but this
is some quite interesting the idea is to
to play in a very sharp fashion if you
place Bishop H phone now okay yeah i
would have gone g5 um okay this is also
an IG for position I guess so why not
this is one idea nigera and queen age
fry you know if if you watch my channel
you know I have a soft spot for that
idea there's a very crude type of attack
but it's surprisingly effective quite
often here again that's it can be it can
get tricky the ayah but then what
actually i doing on that moving the rock
probably and then queen f6 this is
already a very good for black f to the
very truth i play yeah this is so don't
mind that
maybe I could have taken on f2 wind ng5
all right okay this is fine of course
you cannot take only five Queen f2 is
made next move so he needs to play
Bishop to e3 which is demo white resigns
really yeah okay okay yeah this was
quick yeah I'm not quite sure why I mean
obviously this is crap here this
position is terrible but it's a very
quick design of course what what's the
big issue is that this night is a
fantastic piece and I have a very easy
play yeah it is lost even young he can
resign with the relatively clear
conscience h5 is very strong if it takes
here I play g4 and just pin this piece
so what that means my next move will be
g4 h4 end at the end eh file and this is
really terrible the yeah look at this
line I mean I know it looks completely
crude but it can catch people really am
by surprise he needs to be precise iam I
think one idea in this position is due
to play like that may try to get rid of
this important Bishop one idea in fact I
believe that Bishop g5 is already a bit
I built in precise at least connected
with this move I mean what is the bishop
are in d2 doing really not much I think
he should maybe think of 94 m even
before that but then the heel I mean
it's already getting tricky and after
this blackest is really a clearly better
at C cannot really avoid the game
continuation or losses of all use
material when here can can play look I
have one back but yeah how
is there all right very quick win thanks
for watching